I guess I have a few messages one of
them is current AI is very bad in terms
of health you know how much they
understands the world around us then
I'll explain more specifically some of
the things that I think are missing that
at mila we are working on and then i
have a few words but some things we're
doing that have to do with beneficial AI
maybe not beneficial AGI yet so well i
don't need to spend much time to
convince you that there's been huge
progress in AI in great part due to
progress and deep learning but maybe i
want to mention that the the neural nets
of today are very different from the
numinous of the 9 he's not just because
of depth but things like incorporating
attention mechanisms memory being able
to handle any data structure and not
just vectors and being able to generate
data in a way that you know in the 90s
we have no clue how to do or even until
recently and then of course lots of
applications this is the progress of
generative models over four years from
2014 to do 717 ok but but if you want to
be you know honnest about where we are
you know it's it's it's amazing how
superficial and how shallow in in in a
semantic sense the current models are
and you can see that in in the kinds of
mistakes they make of course many of you
know about adversarial examples that
you're seeing here and the fact that
most industrial applications are really
based on supervised learning which
require humans to define the high-level
concepts that the machines are supposed
to learn about and the other thing maybe
people realize a bit less is that if you
if you look at the kinds of mistakes
they make not just
with adversarial examples but other
kinds of more natural mistakes you see
that as soon as you take the current
models out of their training
distribution they they can fail in
pretty bad ways and and one reason why
this happens is because they they rely
on low-level they tend to rely on
low-level superficial properties like
here in the experiments we did in this
paper last year properties of the the
4yi distribution for the spectrum of the
images which can be manipulated in ways
that humans will not even you know care
about but will completely screw up the
classifiers in a natural language you
can also see lots of examples of failure
even with like the best say machine
translation models or the best language
models for example here you have an
example Google Translate today I just
pick recently from a queue coming from
Hofstadter if you try to translate from
English in their house everything comes
in pairs there's this car and her car
his doubles and her towels blah blah
blah in French the translation is is
wrong because it's just basically going
translating his Tusa and her to saw it
unfortunately in French is the same word
and so it completely loses the meaning
and you know in French you would have to
change the actual structure of the
sentence to get it right so so it's like
these these machines are very myopic and
they've they basically learn little
approximate rules that are all you know
stuck together but no overall
understanding of what the sentence
really means you can also see this by
looking at the performance of these
systems when you you ask pointy
questions about the meaning of course
when you when you measure like
statistical performance and tasks like
machine translation looks good in fact
some people claim oh I've just read
something recently oh we got machine
translation reached human level accuracy
this is [ __ ] right because you know
of course in numbers or even like
computer vision right we have not
reached
level computer vision in spite of what
you might read because of course if you
take a data set and you just count how
many errors it looks good but then if
you focus on the errors and you see the
kinds of errors that are made they're
very different from the ones human make
so for example if you try to train a
system to answer questions about like
what is they referring to in these
sentences humans will get at 100%
accurate because they understand the
meaning behind the words so the women
stop taking pills because they were
pregnant or carcinogenic then of course
they were forced to women or pills and
current state of the art systems that
are based on deep learning of course do
only barely better than chance I mean
they're able to pick up some cues but
and and in general if you try to compare
our best systems to babies one year olds
two year olds three year olds the the
the our systems don't even have the sort
of understanding of the world in terms
of intuitive physics or intuitive
psychology that that's more children
have now a bit more than a decade ago
young the current I would this paper
where we sort of laid out our objectives
for deep learning in terms of the notion
of disentangling the underlying factors
which explain the data and and the idea
is that if we can learn a hierarchy of
representations where at the top level
we really have figured out the important
factors that explain the data then we're
going to get much better generalization
because in in that space you can you can
you can learn new information much more
easily how to relate variables now
becomes a very low dimensional learning
problem more recently I've come to
realize that it's not just about
learning which variables matter to
explain the data but also how these
variables are related to each other
which could be in terms of thinking how
the data was generated or thinking about
how to perform computation in a way
that's gonna be efficient so there's a
notion of disentangling computation as
well factorizing knowledge either in in
the genitive sense or
in the computational sense and as I'll
try to argue later this has a lot to do
with the ability of models to figure out
causal structure in the world something
that we don't really know how to do yet
so so this notion of design tangling
representations we elaborated a bit more
in 2013 review paper with erinkoval and
Pascal Vincent and and the general idea
was that we'd like to transform the data
and a space where the relationships
between the variables are very simple
right and so because they're going to be
very simple they're going to be very
simple to learn as well so I mean the
extreme case of this is the the most
common assumption in many deep
generative models is what we call
marginal independence assuming that in
the right representation all of the
variables all those factors are
marginally independent of each other
I think that's too strong of an
assumption most interesting variables
that the kinds of concepts we manipulate
are not independent of each other but
the dependencies are simple and they may
be due to for example simple rule like
type of high-level knowledge that we
communicate at language
another thing that I've studied and I
think is important in relation to
causality is that the kinds of factors
we tend to talk about in in natural
language have to do with how we can
control the world or how other agents
can change things in the world right so
we we like to give names to things that
can be changed in a way that can be
understood easily so so this is a notion
of controllable factors and I'll mention
the conscious prior in a couple of
slides
so one one thing that helps understand
where we are versus where we want to go
is the distinction in cognitive tasks
between what Kahneman and others call
system 1 and system 2 tasks so system 1
tasks are the the tasks that we do using
basically are in
tuition we can do them really fast and
and the way that we solve these problems
are essentially heuristic they're not
perfect right and it's all happening at
the unconscious level we don't know how
to explain we do how we do these tasks
and and so it's it's it's not linguistic
and deep learning currently does really
well at this kinds of tasks but of
course there are other tasks like if I
ask you to add two large members you can
do it in your head or using paper and
it's gonna be slow you're gonna use
logic it's gonna be sequential and you
can do it consciously and explain it
linguistically and this is what
algorithms in computer science really
are about and this is also what
classically I was trying to deal with
obviously our brain is doing both of
these things like most of the work is
done by system one but we need we need
the two of them especially if we want to
have machines that can interact with us
in a natural language and so one of the
things I'm gonna say here as a
recommendation for the path towards AGI
is we can't continue doing the kind of
natural language research where we only
train on text data we have to build
systems that simultaneously can
understand words in sentences but also
what those words refer to in some
environment so this is called grounded
language learning and there is some work
in that direction but I think it's gonna
dominate in the future in the ability of
delivering systems that can actually
understand what the sentences mean so
recently with a group of my colleague at
CFR we laid out a plan for the next five
years about we're where we want are our
deep learning research to go next so let
me go through four of these points one
is you know move the focus from passive
observation to active agent so basically
agents of course we've been doing
reinforcement learning but up to now
it's been you know kind of a separate
thing in in machine learning conferences
and and what I'm saying is in order to
move towards edgy itis is gonna have to
be part of a lot more of the research
and
and all of these points are related to
each other related to that is well we
have to go beyond perception where we're
already doing pretty well to reasoning
and and planning which are these things
we're doing at the highest levels of
representations that I've been talking
about and and we have to do it in a way
that allows the learner to develop a
full I mean full but but incomplete
model of the world that captures causal
structure so we have a causal model of
the world in our head which allows us to
do things like imagine the situations
that have never happened and will never
happen so-called counterfactuals and
allow us to plan and reason even about
things that are unlikely this is not
something that current machine learning
does well and in doing all of these
things we want to continue on our path
of getting inspiration and producing
synergy with the research trying to
understand how humans are intelligent so
neuroscience cognitive science and so on
it's been very important for my work and
and and many of my colleagues to drive
our exploration of AI and and I believe
that there's a lot more that we can gain
and of course we can also give back to
neuroscience and cognitive science with
the models we're building to help them
understand how the brain actually works
so to summarize one of the things we
want to do is joining system 1 and
system 2 using grounded language
learning where we we build high-level
representations of what is going on but
that are anchored in in low-level
perception and and where the the the
meaning of the words is not just like
some word embedding but it is also
connected to actions and the level
perceptions so one of the practical like
nitty-gritty questions on that path is
should we like first learn a world model
think about like a baby which doesn't
act in the world and just or me the acts
in the world but does
speak sorry and that's in here language
and just tries to figure out the physics
of things and then later once we know
how the world works and we just tag
words on these things and we learn the
language model or should we do both
things at the same time so this is an
interesting question and and and my view
on this is that we should do both at the
same time although of course learning
the world model is like the the primary
thing that needs to drive things if you
think about babies when they're born
usually of course their knowledge of
language is zero and except they already
know a bit about the sounds and so the
main thing they initially learn is about
how things work in the world from a
physical this is a physical point of
view and how other human beings behave
some clues that this is the right thing
to do include things like well the fact
that if you train with supervised
learning these imagenet classifiers the
representations you're getting so you
know forget about the classifier itself
but just the representations you're
getting at the top hidden layer are
really really good and they allowed to
generalize to new categories that have
been have been never seen and if you
think about it in in the case of these
classifiers we are using human knowledge
of high-level categories by by doing
supervised learning I mean it's not like
a complicated language we're just saying
the names of things right and so by
doing that where I get actually getting
representations that are much better
than the representations we get if we do
pure unsupervised learning where we
don't provide any labels so providing
labels is like providing a mini language
to those learners and it actually helps
them discover better representations of
of the visual world right so so this is
a clue that you know we we really want
to have not purely ins provides learning
but eventually having language input to
drive these what are called BBE eyes
okay so so part of this is how do we
learn these models of how the world
works and and I think this is going to
be absolutely necessary to deal with the
current problem of systems that can be
fooled very easily so there's there's
also like a robustness and an even
safety issue with current systems I
think about you know self-driving cars
being in a very rare and dangerous
situation that has never been seen and
as statistically unlikely current
methods I think would tend to fail on
these situations but but humans can
imagine these situations even before
they occur and and and learn to behave
properly and and and we're able to do
that because and what happened with the
title but because we have good model of
the underlying causal mechanisms and in
this allows us to generalize in in a
non-trivial way so traditional machine
learning has been about IID Javas ation
so the training data and the test data
are supposed to come from the same
distribution
we've been living with this hypothesis
for decades but it's it's wrong it's not
like what humans do is not what the
system's we build for applications
actually mean because we train on data
from say a particular country and then
we want this to work on another country
so so that assumption leads to lack of
robustness and and people have thought
for a long time that well that's the
best we can do if we have that
assumption then we can get guarantees of
generalization if if the test data
doesn't come from the same distribution
as the training data and what guarantees
do we have right well so what I claim is
that we can we can get a more powerful
form of translation by relaxing the
assumption but still having some
assumption it's just weaker and the
assumption is that the weaker assumption
is is that the the the scenario where
we're going to be using this system
corresponds to a distribution that may
be different from the training one but
involves the same causal mechanisms and
the same underlying concepts right you
can have the same underlying concepts
and the same underlying causal mechanism
but the dispersion is very different
think about you know taking pictures
here on earth and then taking pictures
on the moon it's the same underlying
physics but we get very different
looking
right so what changed is it's the same
dynamical system like you know the
physical gotta make the system but but
initial conditions
maybe the gravity of the Moon is very
different and and maybe also actions
that agents take like you intervene and
you change things in the world are gonna
change particular variables in that
dynamical system leading to potentially
very very different observation
distribution okay so how do we get there
one direction that has already been
taken in our field and I think is gonna
be again central to reaching AGI is to
use simulated environments right so why
does it make sense even if our simulated
environments are really simple compared
to the real world actually I think we
can learn a lot from that and the reason
is that this is like a subtle thing
we're not trying to build AI or AGI
right now as like build the system that
understands how our world works
it looks like that's we want to do but
actually what we're trying to do in
machine learning research is fine the
learning procedure which if it was put
in our world could figure out how our
world works right and we can test those
learning procedures in simpler context
that we can analyze and break down into
gradually more complex requirements and
and that's what I and others are
proposing to do so I think eventually
will converge to some sort of benchmarks
which I think was tagging proposed to
call them AI Olympics where different
research groups would propose different
environments where each research group
would have to deliver learners that can
deal with all of these environments
right and you can think of this as a
more sophisticated Turing test that we
would grow the difficulty of these tasks
as we make progress in research so we've
actually started this with a project
called the baby AI platform and we found
that even with a very very simple
environment which is like a grid world
associated with language constructions
that have a compositional nature so
there's an almost infinite number of
potential instructions of the form
things like you know navigate to this
place and and put something next to
something else the the tasks currently
are extremely difficult even for the the
current best reinforcement learning and
imitation learning systems that we have
so these really really easy easy tasks
that humans can probably learn how to
times faster need hundreds of thousands
or millions of demonstrations to be
learned so so so in a sense I mean it's
it's bad news in the sense that oh we're
really very far from AGI and the good
news is that means we can study those
problems in setups that are simpler and
easier to analyze that don't require as
much computational power so what else is
missing so if you think about how
current machine learning and RL are are
modeling the world I think in addition
to the causality aspect there are there
many other issues so for example our
current typical model think of
predicting the future as a sequence of
one step prediction like I'm gonna
predict the next frame and then given
that and the previous ones I'm gonna
predict the next one and so on so we
typically have these decompositions by
conditional probabilities of the next
thing and then the next thing and the
next thing and that's not at all how
humans build visions of the future right
we can project ourselves at arbitrary
points in the future we don't need to to
have like a little movie in our head of
all the intermediate time steps we could
say something like tomorrow I will do
this and I don't need to predict all of
the intermediate time steps in addition
when I say tomorrow I will go to the
beach I'm just talking about the beach I
don't need to talk about all of the
other aspects of the future state of
what will how the world will be tomorrow
and you know the world is in streaming
complex and has maybe you know tens of
thousands of interesting variables I
could talk about in
language but I'm choosing to only talk
about one or two or three in that
sentence and and we do that all the time
when we project ourselves into the
future planning or imagining or
constructing hypothetical situations so
so this notion of focusing on just a few
variables at a time in our mental
projections is something that's missing
in current machine learning and this is
something I proposed last year and the
paper called the consciousness prior
which which actually considers that this
ability that we have to talk about the
world using just a few variables at a
time is actually a an important
statistical advantage and and so that's
the reason I call it a prior because
it's assuming something about the world
it's assuming that only looking at a few
variables like tomorrow it will rain I
can actually make statements that have a
high probability of being true this is
very very different from if I have to
make a prediction about all of the
pixels you know tomorrow and if if I
were to to try to make these kinds of
predictions in the wrong space in the
space of pixels for example I wouldn't
be able to make very good predictions if
I'm trying to predict one pixel given
three other pixels even if I pick those
pixels well it's not gonna work very
well right if I'm trying to predict how
things will be tomorrow but but if I can
talk in the high-level language of say
it's gonna rain tomorrow seeing I think
it will go a little bit away and
actually then I'm actually able to make
these these very powerful statements and
and that's what we are exploiting when
we say things about the world in
language this is also what classically I
was exploiting with you know the notions
of rules and the variables that are
associated with that so so so now what
this is saying is in addition to this
notion of finding the right space where
we we want to make those statements we
also need to learn those statements
which are those rules right and you can
also think of them as the causal
mechanisms
which relate the variables together in a
graphical model sense all right I mean
let me skip that um so because I use the
word consciousness and this is something
that interests people here let me sort
of now sneak in my view on consciousness
so I think we're confounding I mentioned
it yesterday
we're confounding lots of different
things that computationally are just you
know different they're related when we
talk about consciousness and and none of
those here include the notion of moral
agent moral agent and moral patient
which is actually the notion that we
care about when we say are we what
should we do if we have a conscious
machine should it have rights and things
like that I think this is one aspect
which has to do with social interactions
and social contract but but really there
are computational aspects which are
which can be studied separately and
build in machines in ways that I don't
think are so complicated so
self-consciousness is just having a
notion of my state within the bigger set
of my model of the world access
consciousness is what I'm exploding in
the implementations of the consciousness
prior that I talked about where we only
focus on a few things at a time right
this is attention and this is the things
we're focusing on are these thoughts
that we have at a particular moment
emotions well I mean emotions are just
shortcut calculations to predict the
value of some future state or expected
value of future States in socially
context-dependent
setups and and those those sort of
predictions are very powerful for us the
influence what goes in our memory the
things we choose unconsciously to
remember and in and how our next action
are gonna be decided and then finally
maybe the one that's the most
problematic is the notion of subjective
experience or subjective perception and
I believe this is an overblown issue I
think that even with current Neil Nets
that learn too
the world what they have is actually
subjective perception each of these
neural Nets is trained on different data
and and develops different
representations of the world so if you
think about the color red right well for
those in your Nets the color red is not
the wavelength it's it's these
high-level representations of red things
which for some neural net may be
associated with positive experiences
there for some other neuron that may be
some negative experiences and may be
associated with particular aspects of
the world that could be different from
one individual to the other quickly AI
progress comes and the path to AGI comes
with all kinds of hopes and dangers I
don't need to maybe go through that list
I mean just mention a few things that
we're doing at Mila so we we've been
part of the work on the montreal
declaration for the responsible
development of AI which you can think of
as a more elaborated version of the
Asilomar principles there are ten
principles each of them has things like
your well-being equity diversity
prudence responsibility each of them is
then you know broken down into sub
principles which I think go beyond just
AI but also the values that we care
about as was the case for the Asimov
principles we were also involved in
organizing workshops and events like the
AI for a good workshop at the last nibs
and we have an upcoming workshop on or
school like I'd say on bias and
discrimination in the eye and one thing
I really care about as AI we believe
that it's important to Democrat eyes AI
around the planet and in particular to
make sure that developing countries can
can build their expertise in the eye so
we have a program to bring in students
undergrad or grad from developing
countries like Africa and and spend a
few months at Mila we have projects in
of course applied AI in things like
healthcare and now climate change let me
mention one project which
I find cool that we just started yeah
because I think it's related to some of
the issues discussed here about global
governance and and how to how to make
people on earth and move towards the
better collective decisions so so one
issue with climate change is as people
don't really understand emotionally what
the importance of this because because
what we're seeing in the media and in
papers is very abstract it's happening
you know 50 or 100 years into the future
and even if there's gonna be hundreds of
millions of people dying because of
these things it's hard to make it
personal and emotionally grounded and so
what we're proposing is to use machine
learning in a in a positive way in an
ethically correct way to convince people
of the importance of climate change in a
way that's gonna be emotionally grounded
so for example we can use variations on
Gans to present images of your house or
of your descendants in 50 years or
hundred years as a consequence of the
current decisions about about climate
change the last thing I want to mention
this is really my last slide so this is
a little bit more I know many people
might disagree with this here but the
about existential risk so I do think
that AG AI and AI in general comes with
lots of risks but one that I'm less
confident about less convinced of is the
the risk of really really fast sort of
exponential self-improvement once we
reach AGI I don't think that there's
gonna be like one cutoff point oh we we
reach human-level AI and then suddenly
it's sort of shoots off I don't I don't
I don't believe that
why so so if if the future area is
building machine learning and the kind
of machine learning I understand now and
I can imagine in the future then the
change like the self improvement is not
something that can happen very quickly
it's something that changes very slowly
through learning right
and you know by sort of regent of a
based optimization the other thing is
learning involves actually diminishing
returns in terms of you know the amount
of knowledge obtained as you collect
more data so even if I multiply the
amount of data by a thousand I don't get
a thousand times sort of more efficient
classifiers in fact you-you-you have a
sort of exponential wall here that's
well understood in learning theory and
and similar and similarly yeah so so
rather the the competence probably grows
something like log of the number of
examples and another clue is that the
size of the brain doesn't seem to be
such a big factor like even if we had a
brain that was ten times bigger I'm not
sure we would be sort of ten times
smarter consider you know the fact that
whale brains are much bigger than ours
and I think the main difference between
Wales and us is that we have a culture
and and that allows us to gather much
more knowledge in the same size brain
and the other last point is if you look
at at computer science theory and
machine learning theory you find many
many exponential walls so the opposite
of exponential improvement is basically
things become exponentially hard as you
try to to solve some problems because of
things like the curse of dimensionality
and and all kinds of exponential growth
that make for example search
exponentially hard as you consider
harder and harder search problems all
right I'm closing here thanks
[Applause]
I'm very surprised would you say I'm
very surprised oh um you talked about
the diminishing returns of more data
yeah but I think that's actually when
we're talking in this regime of ID data
on a single pass sure I agree I agree
that active learning we can do a lot
better but we don't have really proof
that active learning except in the
simplest setting oh but I'm not talking
about learning I'm talking about
multitask learning and horizontal
transfer yeah but that's only here it's
linear well it's actually I would argue
it's at least linear which is much
better than logarithmic and potentially
super linear because we see positive
transfer right now when you train on
multiple tasks so I guess if you had an
AI that was very competent on one task I
wouldn't be surprised if it could
rapidly become competent on a whole host
of tasks for instance everything that
humans can do and more I agree but I
don't think you get the kind of
exponential growth that people are
afraid of that so of course I'm all for
multitask learning it's very important
other question I'm sure you do
thank you for your wonderful speech and
I have a short question and a
two-question a first question is if
consciousness player is a kind of access
consciousness yes
and second question is in this is right
after yourself infirmity is a deep spot
you think but if the AI get some kind of
common sense
then they can a program other AI who IND
of course well there are some
possibility to explain self what do you
think about it well humans are really
really bad at programming actually so if
we get human level performance I mean
ability it still sucks in terms of the
ability of programming things so i i'm
i'm open to demonstrations that i should
be much more concerned and i've already
voiced that to a number of people and
and you know i'm glad to engage in that
discussion because I do care that we
don't make tragic mistakes but I haven't
seen a convincing argument yet that
being said I think that where there's a
common ground between my view and many
people here is that you know whatever we
think about the existential risk coming
from super intelligence there's a large
risk coming from abuse of AI from humans
who could control it and potentially
even accidental you know destruction of
people and wealth by people and
especially nefarious use hi yeah you
seem to insist on this idea of a
spectrum of consciousness that's right
which I agree with but don't you think
there is a phase transition that should
that could could arise like being like
solid liquid gas and then consciousness
is maybe just like many different kind
of gases but is there a phase transition
that is sharp and really cut off there
could be so because I have decomposed
consciousness a number of aspects and
for some of those aspects I can see like
gradual improvement like you get better
and better representations or you can
model more and more aspects of the world
or you can
search more efficiently right so there
are many ways in which you can get
progress and maybe some of these are
like qualitative jobs that's quite
possible yeah thank you
we've talked about a number of these
points and it says so I really agree but
on the causality thing yeah so human
intuition about causality is heavily
linguistically based and it's heavily
from embodied distances of of agency yes
whereas you know there's these you know
sort of mathematical causal graphical
models right notion of causality which
is not necessarily the same thing very
somewhat related but humans are actually
kind of bad at this kind of problem you
know right
Kahneman is that right right no wonder
you you know on which of these you mean
well so so we're bad because we're not
good at search but what we're good at is
that figuring out the right variables so
and those variables are the ones we're
talking about that the ones we're giving
names in language great talk i wanted to
dive into some of the things you said
earlier about learning the benefits of
learning about the environment and
learning language at the same time yes
you can get these higher level
abstractions more quickly yeah certainly
seems true in short but what are the
cost might be that you learn the what
say my extractions that we know about
and my understanding is person is when
when machines are learned to diagnose
cancer from different images they
sometimes come up with new kinds of
abstractions that none of us had thought
of before right so maybe talk a little
bit about the trade-off of locking into
our pretty good but not perfect set and
maybe there are other ones especially
since they have other tense days that
they might be able to draw so I believe
in gradual progress in science and I'd
be very happy if we have machines that
already have our intelligence and now if
you wanted to be more ambitious and and
have machines that have a lot more
intelligence then you might want to free
them a bit more from the constraints if
you want of our language and our culture
although keep in mind that these are not
hard constraint
it's more like you're booted up with
that knowledge and now you know humans
can discover new things and those
machines could discover new things as
well so we could explore both
[Music]